overseas battle lines appear to be
tightening over russia's potential
invasion into neighboring ukraine nato
and other european leaders are pleading
for diplomacy ahead of face-to-face
talks between the u.s and russia in
geneva next week christina raffini has
the latest from the white house this
morning christina good morning
good morning dana the white house is
pushing back against a report that said
the biden administration might be
willing to consider lowering troop
levels in eastern europe if russia would
pull back its forces from near ukraine a
senior state department official told
reporters yesterday i want to be crystal
clear that is not accurate and yet the
putin problem remains
russia's aggressive actions are a threat
to peace and security in europe in a
rare friday news conference secretary of
state anthony blinken threatened massive
consequences for further russian
aggression in europe but said diplomacy
is still an option is there concern that
the talks next week are russia's
building up of a pretext for if and when
they fail
using them as justification to go ahead
and invade i think that's certainly part
of the playbook the u.s wants russia to
reduce its troop presence along
ukraine's eastern border where russian
forces annexed crimea in 2014. russia in
turn has made its own demands including
that no new countries be allowed to join
nato
both the u.s and nato have called that a
non-starter it will not compromise on
core principles
including the right for every nation to
decide its own path including what kind
of security arrangements you want to be
part of
a u.s intelligence report estimated the
nearly hundred thousand russian forces
near ukraine could be ready to invade at
the start of this year
this week russian paratroopers landed a
neighboring kazakhstan after its
president requested help controlling
anti-government protests i think one
lesson of recent history
is that
once
russians are in your house it's
sometimes very difficult to get them to
leave
now president biden has said u.s forces
won't be going into ukraine but they
might be needed in nato allied countries
around eastern europe if russia decides
to venture past its borders jeff
christina thank you